hey guys it's Justine and today I am
testing out this brand new bike from
specialized it's an electric bike it's
40% lighter than most electric bikes on
the market I can go up to 28 miles an
hour and up to 80 miles when you're
using the Eco mode I am really excited
to test this out I am NOT new to the
electric bike market but what I am new
to is actual bike riding it's been such
a long time since I actually wrote a
real bike as opposed to an electric bike
with a throttle I'm a huge fan of the
super 73 bikes but this is something
completely different there's off eco
sport turbo and in their smart control
which you can connect your bike to an
app and I'll let you adjust all kinds of
settings when it's connected through
bluetooth you can get a portable range
extender which will extend your ride
another 40 miles if you do need to go
further or just have a backup battery
that is an option I cannot wait to try
this out I've already actually tried it
out so I can't wait to try it out for
you guys in this video this is the Votto
SL 5.0 version jenna is testing out the
Vado 4.0 and i have the Votto 5.0
equipped mine's a 12 speed versus a 10
speed and this one also has future
shocks suspension the equipped version
has a few extra goodies like this rack
mount the fender and a kickstand do a
full comparison of all over the models
check out specialized website for all
the details also pretty excited about
this I've been looking for a really good
helmet to get because we do ride bikes
quite often so this is really cool this
helmet is actually equipped with anji
it's specialized bikes emergency
response so if you crash you connect it
to an app it'll alert your emergency
contacts and hopefully send help they
also have these available just to clip
to existing helmets
so I guess Jen and I are gonna go out
for a ride now where's your mask at we
gotta get masked up so over the past 50
days I basically have spent in the house
Los Angeles is slowly starting to open
back up but I do not plan on going
around people for quite a while Jenna
has a little bag like this is so light
20n oh my gosh I hear so this is about
33 pounds if I were to see this I
actually would probably don't even think
that this was an electric bike and I
think that's kind of part of the appeal
you will be able to get two times the
output that you put into it depending
upon which mode you put it into and this
will take you all the way up to the
turbo settings and you can adjust in
between here and this will determine
what mode you're on so right now
everything is off and take it from there
take it out for a ride I got to get my
mask
[Music]
we made it down to the closed beach you
can't actually ride anywhere near the
beach there's a bike path that's still
open so we're gonna take that it's crazy
cuz my legs hurt so I feel like it
really got a workout just coming down to
Santa Monica here I'm gonna switch out
my camera do a nice 360 and head back
down and keep riding oh my god meeting
outside is so incredible but it's also
so weird
I don't know
[Music]
it's crazy there's no way this is gonna
be the real test
oh yeah oh yeah I'm going
[Music]
I bet everybody thinks I'm so fit
that was awesome
[Music]
just got back from the ride and my
highlight was testing out that Santa
Monica incline because on a normal bike
that would have been pretty impossible I
feel like for me in my current state of
not having biked in a really long time
but this actually made it super simple
everything was incredibly seamless and
the fact that it is still a bike first
and you do have to actually shift gears
is it didn't feel like I could ride for
much longer
I think that was honestly one of my
biggest holdouts from getting a normal
traditional bike is I didn't know if I
would actually be able to get back if I
went and biked somewhere so having that
added confidence of knowing that I do
have that pedal assist if I need it I
can turn it on if I don't want it I can
turn it off taking this out for a test
drive today was really fun I look
forward to having more trails and things
opening up so I'll be able to actually
ride it out more but being able to just
ride it around the neighborhood and all
for Santa Monica has been really great
man though when you put this thing in
turbo and you want to go you go
[Music]
[Applause]